what Sicilian for me by the way because
made sounds like cruel
what's although we could use probably
average message maybe I'm gonna put that
up you know what are the things I used
to get really frustrated across about
was when there are lots of different
words for the same thing I was like a
lot of people just decided one word so I
have to remember so many things then I
realized whatever it is a word or an
idea and you see lots of requests for
that means something water it means that
lots of people like this idea or is well
they use it all the time and so
different beers with people often
comment different words to say the same
thing in their context so what that
means is that's equal to you hey this is
an idea which comes up over and over
again it's highly and okay so we don't
call it not the answer but how do we in
what way do we calculate the okay so as
I like work just indicate what it is the
way to before we get to the answer so
presuming we can calculate what this is
going to be is that all I need to do
together me what what happens have
covered is is at the second this is just
finding I guess this is the total of all
the scores you have your that what do i
do you know testing so I'm gonna need to
do a division I have how many guys in
this case five salsify has it you want
already calculate the total before to
fine you go ahead eternal is the cookie
is a duty can we get to not even green
we're testing
and that means when I buy my client I
should get Israel 10 which is a relief
because I was trying to mentally tough I
suppose that would give you something
nice happy times we remember how to
calculate their mail now in many cases
this is exactly how you were used to be
this kind of classic way you got the
lines and then you need to do the
division and find out okay but
occasionally things will be we'll be
able to use this technology in a
slightly different way for example how
about at the same time numbers I'm
supposed to suppose they were your
scores on a test like a series of tests
okay so you've done five tests for each
one of them you both up to ten minutes
cool I guess that last test was really
really hard okay now suppose what I
wanted you to say was okay I would like
you now to work out any of a new score
on to be simply line though you've got
one more test coming up a sixth test and
I would really love to bump up my
average by meeting from 10 to say I must
be really ambitious tribe of up to 12 so
I'm trying to think myself alright I'm
going to need to score something on the
next test so that when I do my
technicians
how would I go about company where would
you like me to write so maybe you want
to drive down with me if you've got
another car because they're doing the
question so I'm going to say plus X what
is this signify us or Nelson take a look
what would that be good so whenever we
have something but we don't know what it
is and we just see the name and then we
start working with it and the number is
what should I saw or the next okay so
you guys told me to calculate the mean
yeah
and then the second step was you divided
right so now that I don't have five
scores anymore what am I gonna have to
do the denominator it's going to be 6
because there will be six now um what
other information did I tell you before
I wanted the gold
I wanted my new me everyone I wanted it
to instruct right so I'm kind of like I
want to end up on 12 multiple tens so
let's think about this for a second I
know that their denominator on this step
will be divided by six so I wonder if
anyone can coach a tender let's see if
somebody has the Cindy thing yet come on
I know you guys are gonna be great
I got seats
I'm trying to work out what should the
numerator because I bailed me out
this is both 19th on 12 okay I know in
my previous life I'm gonna have
something and this is divided by 6 I
want the answer to 12 what are you 12
very good so you see we've
reverse-engineered what we're doing here
which is division by 6 the opposite of
that is simply very good so that's
multiplying by the way not that you
means no but yeah but we have a fancy
name for this when you take some
operation and you trendy the opposite of
that we call that the inverse right so I
want to do it as a division which as
married it was okay have I got X yeah
can I
is this enough information to work out
what X should vary
[Music]
- that mean - yeah fantastic so in case
you didn't quite catch that right
previously we add up all these scores
and we knew what the total was yeah now
go ahead up all these sports than you
got over and I don't wanna end up at 50
I want to end up at 72 and the
difference of course is going to 22 soon
man should be the actual answer that we
want can we just do a quick check
I mean you've got a calculator there I
make you do this mentally if you took 11
is 9 plus 9 and so on and you had 22
right if you then divide by 6 did you
get the mean that we were does it check
out approachability even before you do G
calculator you were convinced enough by
the working that we did to say okay